bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien bonne fête de l'halloween vous
remarquerez que j'ai mis les couleurs
d'halloween je suis moi même habillé
couleur citrouille je voulais faire une
petite vidéo un petit peu original pour
halloween pour marquer un petit peu le
coup mais j'avais déjà fait une vidéo ya
longtemps sur halloween mais j'ai pensé
un petit truc j'ai fait un point qu à
martha donc ma copine c'est la preuve
que je fais ça c'est peut-être la
dernière puisque j'ai pas mal galéré
alors c'est pas un point qu'avec des
hélicoptères des tanks des feux
d'artifice c'est plutôt un petit plug
homemade familiale bonne ambiance mais
quand même un peu flippant j'aimerais
pas du tout qu'on le fasse avant que je
commence à penser à mettre un petit
pouce en l'air et à vous abonner à ma
chaîne
si ce n'est déjà fait en gros le concept
je sais que martha est super fans de
films d'horreur des trucs qui font
flipper en gros j'ai fait en sorte qu'il
se retrouve tout seul à la maison et
j'ai mis en place un petit scénario tout
simple mais inspirés de films d'horreur
qu'on a tous déjà vu la télé qui
s'allument avec la neige dessus les
portes de placards de la cuisine ouverte
comme dans le sixième sens pas un truc
comme ça je vais très bien que si je
faisais un truc trop cliché genre à une
musique d'halloween un gros fantôme un
taux qui allait tout de suite grille est
donc le but c'était de faire des choses
un petit peu sur le fil un peu crédible
et un peu flippante en même temps et à
la fin moi je dois arriver comme ça
habillé en gros monstre chelou
finalement j'ai opté pour le masque de
saut à voir le monstre au final
[Rires]
on aura fort
la tenue de mon perso et plus classe que
ma vraie tenue dans la vie on va pas
avoir peur du tout évident mais c'est
bien là
c'est clair mais n'en dit non parce que
sinon je sais que j'ai la version à 10
ans tu vas l'avoir réservé aux
évidemment pour justifier le fait qu'on
a truffé la maison de dix caméras j'ai
fait croire qu'on faisait un blog sur la
décoration d'halloween le truc le moins
intéressant du monde du coup elle ya cru
j'ai un peu n'importe quoi mais je crois
que c'est passé et on a même commencé à
filmer pour de faux ce blog que rossi
bonjour à tous on va faire un petit bloc
de décorations d'halloween c'est une
vidéo consacrée à la déco
allez moi ça le plan il est beau c'est
faire un truc qui marquera l'histoire ça
maintenant
donc tout d'abord on a fait semblant de
partir donc d'abord les filles avec la
nounou
[Musique]
et nous on devait attendre qu'elle se
pose dans la chambre pour avoir bien le
temps que moi je voulais placards de la
cuisine etc on ice se cacher dans mon
bureau sauf que comme par hasard ce jour
là à ce moment là elle a décidé d'être
super active
à
et finalement au bout d'un moment elle
se pose enfin pour se maquiller et donc
là c'était feu vert
[Musique]
j'ai posé la trottinette de notre fille
devant la porte d'entrée un peu inspiré
de shining même si dans shining c'est
plutôt un tricycle mais bon on l'a dit
au revoir
on sait bien planqué dans mon bureau et
là on a laissé passer dix petites
minutes pour que le truc soit un petit
peu crédible donc au début tout est
calme la maison est parfaitement
silencieuse martha se maquille tout va
bien et la distance je commence à
envoyer la neige dans la télé
comme choix qu'elle réagit pas trop à la
neige augmente le son jeu l'augmenta
fonds et commence à flipper
et là je commence à envoyer la première
phase un peu lourde j'envoie un son de
placards qui claque que je trouve sur
spotify je le mets à fond dans tout le
salon
et
le principe c'est qu'elle débarque dans
le salon et qu'elle voit tous les
placards de la cuisine ouvert c'est à la
fois pas grand chose et en même temps je
te jure si tu es tout seul chez toi tu
vois ça c'est sûr que tu flippes
[Musique]
vous faites une blague mais
elle va voir ce qui se passe sur le
palier et là elle tombe sur la
trottinette
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure elle commence
vraiment à flipper
[Musique]
quand tu es dans le couloir évidemment
on renvoie l'ascenseur à notre étage
sans personne dedans
l'âge active la descente de l'écran
géant dans le salon moi parce qu'on a un
écran géant je n'ai jamais dit
comment ça a pu rien comprendre ce qui
se passe
même merlin ici mais un flipper
bien sûr à un moment donné j'ai prévu
d'éteindre le courant incidence parole
[Musique]
là ce moment-là gros danger parce
qu'elle vient vérifier dans mon bureau
là où on est caché et on était
franchement pas caché de enfin vraiment
sous le bureau et y avait nos vieux pays
qui sortait et où elle est restée au
moins 30 secondes on a pu respirer
et c'est passé elle est repartie le
point qu à continuer évidemment à
l'essai de m'appeler plein de fois j'ai
pas décrocher par contre mon boire
faisait un son de ouf j'ai trop peur
qu'elle nourrit elle est même sorti sur
la terrasse voir ce n'était pas dehors
mais
hélas je balance un live d'edith piaf me
demandez pas pourquoi je kiffe edith
piaf mais quand tu es tout seul chez toi
la nuit et en temps ça à balles réelles
[Musique]
je sais que c'était le moment en arriver
au bout cela commençait vraiment à
stresser donc je sors de ma tanière
je mets mon fabuleux masque de saut
[Musique]
et c'est dans ce décor d'halloween qu'on
va faire un petit débrief ma chérie tu
t'es fait plaquer pour la première et
peut-être dernière fois parce que c'est
un peu chiant mettre en place c'était
bien fait pointures
bazire mais de musique d'émotion et tu
nous fais une petite rade
les émotions et c'est bien là sentir au
max c'est quand même fou parce que tout
le piège était fait devant mes yeux
toute la journée et je mets participer
elle a totalement participé à mettre les
décorations d'halloween mais j'étais
barak ni des mensonges avait aucun sens
et des sucettes vie hier devant le judas
de toujours regarder dans
ses pronostics à 15% de ici d'hervé site
totalement fait avoir à l'ouvrir c'est
vraiment la télé qui qui évita il a
comme dans les films d'horreur et ça
c'était horrible c'est mon réflexe a été
d'appeler loup non je suis dit soit
c'est un prince soit il ya vraiment
quelqu'un dans la maison et il y a de
calcul qu'il ya ni messi ni toi ni
personne en fait et là j'ai vraiment
j'ai l'habitude pour être totalement un
espion russe en fait ça qui la
trottinette
un grand merci à toutes mes complices
qui ont parfaitement
[Musique]
[Rires]
bon voilà j'espère que vous avez
apprécié cette petite expérience sur ce
les petits boulots je vous souhaite une
bonne fête d'halloween un maximum de
bonheur et à très très bientôt
[Musique]
en